[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRESENTER: In the
1880s, Italians
developed special
machines to make espresso.
As the name implies,
this coffee drink
can be produced in seconds.
Soon the appeal of this quick
brew expanded beyond Italy.
And today espresso is
enjoyed all over the world.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Making good espresso is as
much a science as it is an art.
Professional machines
balanced temperature and steam
pressure to produce espresso
with kick and crema.
Professional espresso
machines are made
of high carbon steel sheets.
Computer program tools
carve different shapes
out of the steel.
These parts will
be the framework
for the espresso machine.
The tools also cut holes for
screws, bolts, and components,
like the steam tab.
An employee places a
freshly cut control panel
into a hydraulic press machine.
The press bends the panel
to the correct shape
and creates tabs for assembly.
This is the panel before
and after bending.
After bending the other panels,
they assemble the framework.
The worker attaches a receptacle
to capture excess water.
He installs meters to
control the flow of water.
They release different amounts
for long or short espressos.
He turns the base right
side up and screws
the side framework to it.
He attaches the front
panel to the sides.
The espresso machine's
framework is now in place.
Next, they make the group heads.
These parts will shoot
hot pressurized water
through the packed
ground coffee.
The worker installs valves that
will regulate the water flow.
The valves also release
built up pressure
so that the filter holders
can be removed after brewing.
The group heads fit into slots
in the front of the framework.
He secures them with
nuts at the back.
He places a large
copper and brass
boiler in the espresso
machine chassis
and connects the water lines.
The tank will generate steam
to froth milk for cappuccinos.
It will also supply
hot water for tea.
Heat exchangers run through
the boiler to supply
the hot water for brewing.
He connects copper pipes
to the heat exchanger
outlets on the boiler.
Then he links them
to the group heads.
The pipes have been
pre-bend in order to easily
fit into the group heads.
He tightens the fitting
for the hot water tap.
Next, he installs the pump
that pressurizes the water.
He screws it to one
side of the framework.
A worker then wires
the electronics
to the front of the machine.
The employee fits the control
panel to the front framework.
He slips rubber molding
around the protruding seam.
Then he screws knobs
onto the levers.
He tucks heating coil into
the upper part of a machine.
The top of the machine
works as a cup warmer.
The espresso stays hot longer
when served in heated cups.
A worker then encases the
steel espresso machine and
polycarbonate molded panels.
The plastic parts are slightly
rounded to make the espresso
machine look less boxy.
He seats a steel drip tray
under the group heads.
And he places the cup tray
over the heating element.
The espresso machine is ready
for the filter basket holders.
They're equipped with winglets
that hook into the group heads.
The worker tests
the espresso machine
to confirm that
there are no leaks
in the hydraulic circuitry.
The machine appears to
be in good working order.
Now it's time for
a coffee break.